well the trance live Richie soon act
said he'd do everything it takes to try
to sort out the economic impact of this
pandemic and we are starting to learn
what that actually means have a look at
this coronavirus job retention scheme it
sounds technical but this is an enormous
move the government will pay 80% of
retained workers salaries it means they
will be paying people to effectively
keep their jobs and stay at home on top
of that you also have v80 payments being
suspended until the end of June a lot of
employee employers businesses had called
for that they've been worried about
those bills coming through in the next
few weeks and as well as that Universal
Credit that guys have a little bit more
generous raised by a thousand pounds per
year that's around 7 billion pounds a
year and let's just give a sense of how
that's
totting up when it comes to the deficit
so how much the government borrows each
year you get a sense of how this stuff
starts to mount this shows you how much
was borrowed each year in recent years
and this is the year we're talking about
the year the coming fiscal year where
all of this is going to take effect of
the budget measures so in the budget
last week 12 billion pounds extra was
given over to covert 19 then on top of
that you have a second package that was
earlier this week 20 billion pounds in
that and then today this third package
so that's seven billion billion pounds
that's on benefits and then on top of
that you have this job retention scheme
could be nine billion pounds could be
even more than that and when you take
that bar in total you're talking about
two percent just under 2 percent of GDP
how does that compare with other
countries well so far the UK has
slightly more there than Italy in terms
of these covert 19 measures slightly
more than the European Commission have
committed about 1% of GDP about the same
as France less than Germany although we
haven't heard about what's going to be
in that but in the u.s. they are
promising to give out checks to every
single citizen enormous measures being
considered in the home of capitalism and
as well in the UK an extraordinary
moment here in a sense capitalism has
been suspended as we know it the
government is going to be paying out
checks to people for just keeping their
jobs and staying at home this is
incredibly unprecedented at times and
it's incredibly unprecedented move just
shows how serious they are about the
economic impact of this virus